this pretty much is a good list for you
to become the ultimate full stack
developer i mean these are the only
technologies i would say more or less
you need in today's time to be a great
full stack developer to build any sort
of application in this video i'll be
sharing the ultimate full stack tech
stack which you should know as a
developer to build pretty much any
application you want in today's time
let's go this video is a part of code
dam's t-shirt giveaway program for the
month if you want to take part and win
an amazing go damn t-shirt all you have
to do is leave a comment on this video
about what you think and that's it you
are eligible if your comment gets a
heart from code damn you will win a
t-shirt for absolutely free and in this
video i would not be starting with the
obvious stuff that is html css
javascript i hope you know that already
i would probably share a bit of my own
tech stack mixed with things i know are
good for you to learn let's start with
next js first of all if you are a react
developer this makes a lot of sense and
this video would be opinionated you
might be a view js developer but i'm
just giving you one option of a solid
tech stack feel free to change the
technologies in this if you would like
to next chase is an awesome server side
rendering framework which will make your
websites more performant faster powerful
as well some of the features but most
importantly this has a great developer
experience inbuilt right so you're gonna
not have a lot of hard time or bad time
building websites with next year's the
next tech stack which i recommend is
tailwind css until when css again
opinionated but i do like it as a
developer because it reduces the
possibilities of layouts you can create
or you know the values as well not the
layouts how that works is that because
you know until when you have either
padding x1 which is one em 2 3 4 5 so it
has from a continuous range where you
can pretty much specify any value in css
to a discrete range this kind of helps
with some same default same value same
gaps if you are not a designer as per
say and for me i'm definitely not a
designer and tailwind css does help a
lot the next thing which i would highly
highly highly recommend anyone and
everyone who's working with the mid to
large size javascript is to move to
typescript this is i think if not the
most important one of the most important
technologies i'm gonna list today in
this video typescript is super important
and it might seem like a weird step back
from you know because javascript is
dynamic language and gives so much
flexibility to moving back to a
statically almost statically typed
language but this discipline this
discipline is super important when
you're working with medium or big size
projects therefore make sure typescript
trust me try script should be at your
agenda for learning if not today then
definitely in a few weeks in a few
months but keep it on your to-do list
next up is graphql and the reason i like
graphql so much is not because well sure
it gives you the advantages of graphs
and you know that complexity which it
brings sure those are advantages but a
couple of more advantages which are
inbuilt are the schemas that means you
would not have weird or funky data
passed to your backend services it kind
of provides some sort of data validation
although i would recommend a library
like joey which is again could be part
of this tech stack i'm just circling the
technologies but schemas do provide data
validation and second of all when you
mix it with typescript you get ultimate
superpowers because plugins like graphql
code gen you can actually generate
static types for your front end as well
so your front end
now can know about how your back end api
responses would look like and this is
trust me this is very very helpful when
you have a lot of api endpoints and you
have a lot of resolvers and a lot of
code coming from front to back this type
safety and this type you know guarantee
is very very very awesome feature of
typescript and graphql code next up is
mongodb and with mongodb i would
recommend mongoose and with mongoose i
would also recommend [ __ ] ts chen or a
package like that and what this third
package does is pretty much what graphql
codes and does to graphql that is you
are able to generate your mongodb types
typescript types for mongodb from your
mongodb schema again mongoose exists
because you have the option to provide a
schema therefore some sort of validation
and stuff this exists because you have
automatic types which again makes your
code so much safe and
so much less headache in terms of
figuring out
some type of bug or anything and yep
mongodb in general is a good nosql
database although sometimes i do
recommend going with sql databases as
well especially if you know beforehand
that your data would be a lot relational
in nature but yeah i mean for now
mongodb is a solid tech stack on the
testing side i would say just as a
runner you know integrated with anything
which you're doing for example for next
year's it might be react testing library
or for api testing it might be just
fetch or axios calls and cypress
is a solid choice for testing
right so this is a solid choice for your
building your testing pipeline cicd
pipeline and stuff like that so make
sure you know how to set up just
correctly because this is just a runner
it's not a testing i mean it does not
include a lot of heavy lifting ah just a
runner for tests and cypress is an
end-to-end testing tool which should be
your priority if not anything in terms
of testing right because this is just
automating your manual test every single
time you build a new feature so make
sure you learn about cypress as well i
have a full course video on that on
codam i'll leave the link in the
description so make sure you see that
more on the utility side i would say
prettier and eslint are a couple of
tools which if you don't have configured
i'm going to judge you real bad
because these tools will help you save a
lot of dev time and save others a lot of
tip time as well so make sure you
configure ptr and eslint on your systems
on the ci cd side i would say github
actions is an important thing which you
should know and figure about how to work
with github in general you'll be
surprised to know so many people who
don't know how to use github properly as
well so make sure you know about github
and github actions for the ci cd part
continuous integration and deployment so
that anytime you push to master or main
or whatever your default branch name is
you pretty much don't have to do
anything you just have to sit back your
code gets built your code gets tested
your code gets deployed that's the
meaning of continuous deployment
continuous integration around the
infrastructure side i would say figure
out how to work with aws lambdas for
example if you are working with graphql
it's best to deploy it as an aws lambda
instead of just managing your own ec2
server and so on until and unless you
have a lot of traffic and then you have
to optimize between you know cost and
the traffic you're receiving then it
will be much more practical choice to go
ahead and compare far gate and lambda
and stuff like this but for starters i
would say aws lambda is a solid choice
for your back end make sure your back
end is stateless it is
serverless compatible with that being
said serverless is a super interesting
tool as well serverless is a cli tool
which helps you
manage your infrastructure as a code
right so if you're working with aws any
sort of service this is the tool which
you need to learn a bit about trust me
this is
super complex thing because aws is a
complex thing that is why this is also
complex you don't have to master it you
don't have to learn it completely but
you just have to know how to configure
your infrastructure as a code because if
your infrastructure is configured as a
code this is a powerful thing why
because anytime you mess something up
all you have to do is redeploy that
thing reward that change back or do
anything but on a code level not on the
on that ui level where you might screw
some option aws updates it the other day
and you are not able to find it so
infrastructure as a code using
serverless is also super important and
finally for nexus i think it goes
without saying but you should be looking
at versailles as a deployment option for
front-end so your graphql back-end sits
on lambdas your front-end sits on versal
i mean that's a match made in heaven
kind of thing because your both the
components right now are scalable and
yeah i mean can pretty much take any
sort of load you throw at them finally
talking a bit about web security which i
always do i do think you should also
look into things like decrypt or
password hashing if you're storing
passwords yourself otherwise you know
oauth authentication for logging in with
google facebook stuff like this but yeah
i mean as long as you're following the
best practices for web security this
pretty much is a good list for you to
become the ultimate full stack developer
i mean these are the only technologies i
would say more or less you need in
today's time to be a great full stack
developer to build any sort of
application with that being said just to
inform we pretty much cover every single
one of these technologies in the code
dam's full stack learning path and we're
gonna be increasing the price of that
really soon once that learning path is
officially completed and launched so if
you're not enrolled in that learning
path make sure you do that the final
discount link is in the description so
yeah i mean make sure you are on that
train to get the full stack learning
path before the prices showed up that is
all for this one i'm gonna see you in
the next video really soon
[Music]
[Music]